>>commentator: Leonard Mlodinow, bestselling
author of the The Drunkard's Walk has a new
book called SUBLIMINAL: How Your Unconscious
Mind Rules Your Behavior, a fascinating and
enlightening look at the profound ways that
the unconscious affects our experiences and
our lives.
Over the past two decades researchers have
developed remarkable new tools for probing
the unconscious or subliminal workings of
the mind and this explosion of research has
led to a sea change in our understanding our
how the mind affects the way we live. With
a new understanding of our own hidden mental
processes that Mlodinow provides in SUBLIMINAL
we are able to recognize and avoid some common
pitfalls in our lives, work, and relationships.
So with that, if you could welcome Leonard
Mlodinow to the stage.
[applause]
>>Leonard: Hi, good afternoon. Thanks for
inviting me here and thanks for taking your
lunch hour to listen to me and also to participate
in an experiment and do a little work on your
lunch hour.
I'm gonna start actually with two experiments
and it's totally voluntary and it's anonymous
so if you want to participate just do what
I ask and if you don't then ignore me.
So the first thing that I need to do is to
divide you into two groups and it's important
as we do the experiment that no one talk and
you just follow the directions you'll see
on the screen. So to divide you into two groups
let's go like right down here, and if you
perceive that you're on this side this line
then call yourself Group 1, and if you perceive
that you're on this side then you're Group
2.
And Group 1 please look at the screen, please
read this silently, and record your answer.
Okay, now please read this question silently
and also record your answer.
Group 1 please turn toward the back of the
room and Group 2 please turn forward.
Group 2 please read this question and record
your answer.
Alright now please read this question and
record your answer here.
Great, now you can all turn forward again.
Thank you.
Now if you're in Group 1 please put a 1 at
the top of your slip of paper and circle it
and if you're in Group 2 put a 2 and circle
that.
[pause]
Okay, now the second experiment.
I need a female volunteer. Come up, please.
[pause]
Thank you. What's your name?
>>Maria: Maria.
>>Leonard: Sorry.
>>Leonard: Maria, thank you. I'm gonna read,
everyone study these words, okay, I guess
hopefully you've been studying them. I'm gonna
read the top line, Maria's gonna read the
second line, and then I'll read the third
line.
Candy, sour, sugar, bitter, good.
>>Maria: Taste, tooth --
>>Leonard: Whoop, whoop sorry. Here come --
[pause]
>>Maria: Taste --
>>Leonard: Whoop, it's not.
>>Maria: Hello.
>>Leonard: There we go.
>>Maria: Taste, tooth, nice, honey, soda.
>>Leonard: Chocolate, heart, cake, eat, pie.
Okay, hope you were listening carefully. Thank
you Maria.
[pause]
Alright now you might be wondering is there
another test coming? Well the answer is yes.
But this isn't it. Whoops, hold on. Don't
write anything, but I want you just to think
of all the words of the list that you can
recall and think of us saying them. Okay,
so spend a minute and focus on that.
[pause]
Alright now –
now comes the test. Either zero, one, two,
or all three of these words were on the list
and I want you to think back, picture either
Maria or I saying, or think back in your mind
if you can hear either Maria or I saying these
words. If you're confident that one of these
words was on the list write it down; it might
be that none of them were on the list, it
might be that all three of them were on the
list, or it might be that one or two of them
were on the list. So I'm not tellin' you which
or how many were on the list, but if any of
them, if you have a, if you're confident that
you have a distinct memory of having seen
one of these on the list or heard us saying
them, please write it down right now. Okay.
Alright, now Group 1 please pass your papers
this way and Group 2 please pass your papers
this way and they'll be collected and tabulated
for our experiment. Thank you.
So while we're collecting the papers let me
begin the talk.
So I call the book SUBLIMINAL: How Your Unconscious
Mind Rules Your Behavior. Why did I call it
SUBLIMINAL? Well some of you may know that
in the 1950's a marketing consultant named
James Vickery said that he was able to subliminally
influence people's behavior by flashing for
just one-thirtieth of a second a sign that
says either, "Drink Coca-Cola" or "Eat popcorn,"
during a movie called Picnic that was playing
in a New Jersey movie theater. And he claimed
that he could increase the sales of popcorn
by I think it was 18% and Coke was 51 or 55%
by having these subliminal messages play in
front of the audience which they did not perceive.
But about five years later, this is the 50th
anniversary of an article in Advertising Age
Magazine in which he admitted that it was
all a hoax; he had a failed marketing business
and he was trying to prop it up with this
trick. But although he admitted that it was
a hoax it never really left the American consciousness
or our culture and so subliminal persuasion
is something that everyone even still recognizes
today.
Some people follow this and don't seem to
have gotten the retraction though, including
one of our former Presidents. This was an
ad that George Bush ran against Al Gore in
which he flashed, or his campaign, flashed
the word rats in the middle of a message for
one-thirtieth of a second and this message
played on TV over an anti-Gore ad and it played
for about 4,000 times before somebody discovered
it and then it was pulled from the air. So
apparently they didn't really get the message.
But actually a few years after this a scientist
decided to test to see whether such subliminal
messages can actually have an effect on people
and they found that even a message such as
this or other messages about drinks can have
a little effect, a fragile effect on people
in the laboratory.
For instance, in one experiment people were
brought into a room and told that they were
gonna see word scrambles and unbeknownst to
them one of the quote word scrambles really
said Lipton Ice. And afterwards the subjects
were offered drinks and far more than who
had seen the Lipton Ice chose Lipton Iced
Tea than those who hadn't seen it.
But nobody really believed you can persuade
someone to like Lipton Iced Tea if you don't
like Lipton Iced Tea or that that effect would
last beyond the laboratory hours later; it's
really something that's hard to reproduce
in the lab and it's very fragile but it does
exist.
One other hand there are many subliminal effects
in your environment that are affecting you
all the time that are much less artificial
than this, and that's really what the book
is about. It's about subliminal effects, meaning
effects that go on below the threshold of
consciousness that your brain picks up, that
your senses pick up, that are processed by
the unconscious part of your brain and feed
into your consciousness perceptions, visual
perceptions, social perceptions, memories,
and they govern the way you behave to a great
extent.
Let me, before I talk about them specifically,
let me define what I mean by unconscious behavior.
An unconscious process in your mind is something
that is automatic and occurs with no effort
on your part and it's outside of your awareness,
you're not aware that it's happening or that
it's influencing you, and it's outside of
your will and largely outside of your control.
So those are the traits that I mean when I
say something is unconscious.
And as a result of that we often don't understand
what's influencing us in our everyday lives
[pause]
and however I wanna point out that the unconscious
I'm talking about is not the Freudian unconscious
that you may have heard a lot of about, it's
not the unconsciousness that was talked about
for most of the 20th century; this is a totally
different kind of unconscious. The Freudian
unconscious was very emotional and it was
hidden from people for motivational reasons.
But the new unconscious that neuroscientists
and psychologists talk about is far different
from that; it's not accessible through therapy
or talking or introspection, but it takes
place in parts of your brain that are inherently
inaccessible to your conscious mind. So even
though Freud was right that a lot of your
behavior is influenced by the unconscious,
most of the specifics of what he talked about
have not found any support in the scientific
community.
[pause]
My book SUBLIMINAL is based on something called
social neuroscience. And social neuroscience,
this slide says it evolved in the mid-1990's
but actually the technology that largely fueled
it evolved in the 1990's but the subject didn't
really gel until the early 2000's; the first
meeting in this field was in 2001. The field
is really a ménage a trois, that's represented
by this slide, those three pairs of feet.
And the feet over on this side represent social
psychology. Social psychology is a psychology
of how people interact with each other; the
psychology of our social interactions.
The feet on this side is cognitive psychology.
Cognitive psychology is psychology of the
way we think and the way we deliberate.
And the feet in the center that brought them
both together is neuroscience, and neuroscience
really exploded in the mid-1990's when something
called functional magnetic resonance imaging
became widely available. And before that fields
of psychologies did behavioral studies but
it was hard to get a good impression or a
good idea, a concrete idea, of exactly what
was going on because we couldn't see into
people's heads.
And functional magnetic resonance imaging
or FMRI allows scientists in a way to see
into people's heads because it provides a
3-D picture not only of the structure of the
brain but of what parts of the brain are currently
active, as you can see here by the yellow
and the red areas. And so it allowed scientists
not only to make speculations about behavior
being unconscious but to trace what parts
of the brain are responsible for conscious
and unconscious behavior and how they interact
with each other.
And one of my favorite studies along these
lines, just to show you how powerful it's
becoming, was done by a fellow named Jack
Gallant who is at Berkeley nearby, and he
showed people a series of images which are
pictured here, there are many more of them,
but here's four of them. And he used the data
solely from the functional magnetic resonance
imaging data to predict what the people were
looking at. So he didn't use any of the data
about what images where actually being shown
but just the readings of these peoples' brains
and he used that to choose images and make
guesses, the computer chose images and made
guesses, as to what they were looking at.
The computer had a database of six million
images to choose from and after taking these
readings as input it spat out what it thought
was its version of mind reading.
So let's see how well it did.
[pause]
So I think that's pretty impressive; you can
see on this side, these black slides here,
show you the computer's guess and the red
slides are what the people were actually looking
at.
[pause]
So I'm gonna talk a little bit about how this
works, how the unconscious mind works in your
life. First I'm gonna talk about the unconscious
and sensory perception because that's very
easy to illustrate and it's something that
I can show you visually here as opposed to
bringing people up and doing little experiments
on you. But I did do two experiments to start
the talk so eventually we'll go and we'll
demonstrate how that works in your own lives,
but first let's look at how it works in vision
and hearing and allow the processes that your
brains use have their analogs in the way we
construct our world, our social world.
I want you to come away with three main points:
one is that our mental processes proceed along
two paths, the conscious and the unconscious
which we're unaware of; secondly that all
of our perceptions, our visual perceptions,
our auditory perceptions, our memories, and
our social perceptions including the way you
see people and the way you see yourself are
not just purely direct reflections of the
data that you take in, but are constructions
by your brain that seem real but really are
made of the data that you've assimilated plus
things like your prior beliefs, your knowledge,
the context, and even your desires.
[pause]
And I want you to see that the way we experience
the world therefore is largely due to this
unconscious processing.
[pause]
Let's start with a little picture here, okay.
I want the men especially to look at this
picture and to look for something unusual
in this picture, okay? Alright so take your
conscious mind, I want you to consciously
search for something unusual in this picture,
alright? Okay. Now that picture had something
in the foreground that psychologists would
call a high interest image--
[laughter]
okay, that's why I said especially the men
in the audience 'cause it's a higher interest
image for men. And how many of you saw something
very unusual in the picture?
[pause]
So okay a handful. How many of you didn't?
Okay, slightly larger handful. But normally
it breaks about one to four or one to three;
the minority see something unusual and the
majority don't. And that's because when light
impinges on your retina your brain doesn't
automatically detect he image and make an
image for you but you have something called
attention that has to be directed in order
for you to see what your, in order for you
consciously perceive what your eyes are seeing.
And this attention is a function of both your
conscious and your unconscious. And in the
case of a very high interest image your unconscious
often wins and has that image dominate so
that you don't really see the lower interest
part of the image.
In this case I'll tell you, unfortunately
this is not the best projector, but do you
see a King Kong there in the background? If
you look at that screen behind you, as least
those of you in the front, it's a lot clearer
I think. To you right, to the right of the
woman as you're looking at her in the bushes
is the face of King Kong.
[pause]
Could you see it now?
[people speaking in background]
On my screen it's perfect, but if you look
on that screen back there I think it's much
more, it's over to the right. I'll show you
it's right here. Do you see it now? It can
be hard to see even if you're looking for
it, but right here is a face of King Kong.
>>male #1: There's also a ladder [inaudible]
>>Leonard: There's also a ladder there that's
in much more contrast, that's right.
Alright let me show you what, when you look,
here's an example of a scene that you perceive
if you look at the road. Now this is the image
that your eye, this is the image that your
conscious mind perceives when you look at
the road. Let me show you now the image that
your retina picks up. Your retina picks up
an image that's only clear in the very center
of the area that you're fixating on, and it's
very fuzzy outside of that and it has a black
spot that you'll see over here which is the
blind spot from where your optic nerve attaches
to your retina.
What your brain does is it takes this and
it uses this data and it uses the data from
both eyes and it fills in the gaps and it
uses the context that you're looking at and
it uses even your expectations and your desires
to present to you a clear image and a three
dimensional image which is not really there.
And you perceive the image, when you look
down the road, you perceive the image as being
real, you don't have to expend any effort
to see the clear image, it comes automatically
and you can't in fact if you look at an image
of the road you can't override these unconscious
processes and see it the way it really impinges
on your retina because all these things are
happening for you automatically. Nature has
created human beings to work this way because
this is how we survived in the wild. If we
had to stop and take the actual core data
that's coming to our eyes and work to reconstruct
it we would never be able to catch our prey
or run from our predators.
[pause]
This is an example of how that works. If you
look at the squares you'll see the square
A and you'll see the square B. Now the square
that's labeled B you perceive as a white square
and you perceive the square that's labeled
A as a black square. This is because you're
looking, you know you're looking at a checkerboard
and you see the shadow from the cylinder and
your eye puts all that together. But this
is not the reality; the reality is that the
square A is identical to the square B; it's
not the same color, it's not any darker or
lighter, it's exactly the same. So I want
you to stare at it and override your unconscious
mind and see it as being the same. You see
it as being different because of the context,
but actually it's the same.
Now here's a couple people who are trying
to blot it out with their hands and that's
the right way to do it. But let me do it electronically
for you, it's a little bit easier. I'm gonna
move the checkerboard away from the squares
and once I move the context away you'll see
that the squares are the same color.
[pause]
There you go.
So what your unconscious mind is doing is
it's creating the reality for you, it's creating
the reality of this checkerboard because it's
useful for you to see it that way, but it's
overriding the actual physical data that a
physicist would say is impinging on your retinas.
[pause]
So you recognize this fellow? Your brain has
a very special area called the fusiform face
area that's used to analyze faces. That's
because human beings are an extremely social
species, we've evolved to have the most complex
social interactions of any other animal and
our brains and our unconscious minds have
also evolved to handle that. So not only does
your unconscious handle physical sensory perception
for you it handles a lot of your social perception.
So the fusiform face area helps you recognize
people because in human society especially
as we were evolving it was very important
to know who's dominate, who's not, who's an
ally, who's an enemy, and how we all relate
to each other. And so we've evolved these
special talents for the social world and our
unconscious mind builds us a picture of the
social world just as it does of the physical
world. The thing about your fusiform face
area is though you don't usually see people
upside down and so it doesn't really work
as well upside down as it does right side
up. So when you look at these pictures they
probably both look like they're pretty decent
pictures of the President. Does any of these
looked grotesquely distorted to you?
>>male #2: [inaudible]
How many of you have seen this before?
[laughter]
That why I shouldn't give this talk at Google,
but let's turn 'em over for you.
[pause]
So this is the actual pictures and now your
fusiform face area seeing a right side up
face kicks in and they look grotesquely distorted,
but it's hard to see when they're upside down,
you can see the image go away as I turn the
picture.
[pause]
Here's another example. Look at the image
on your left: male or female?
>>male #3: Female.
>>Leonard: Female. And the one on the right?
>>male #4: Male.
>>Leonard: Male. Okay, but they're actually
the same person. Not only are they the same
person they are the same image except that
one has been doctored to show more contrast
and one to have less contrast. So you're automatically
perceiving the person as a male or a female
based on certain cues that you're used to
from everyday life and this happens unconsciously
and outside of your control and it doesn't
take any effort.
[pause]
So the moral of all these slides is that our
vision is not objective but rather it's constructed
by our minds employing context, prior knowledge,
belief, desire, and other such factors that
are separate from the actual data that comes
into your eyes.
The same thing happens in hearing. So I'm
going to just briefly give you a couple examples
in hearing and I want you to see how they
are analogous to the same thing that's happened
in vision.
[pause]
I'm gonna play this sentence for you in a
minute where a cough obliterates one of the
sounds. The sentence is, "The state governors
met with their respective legislatures convening
in the capital city."
[pause]
Now I want you to listen very carefully to
this audio file and just as I showed you the
fuzzy picture of the roadside and told you
how your brain fills it in to make it a clear
picture, your brain is also gonna fill in
the sound that obliterated by this cough and
you're gonna hear a pretty normal sentence.
[audio file being played]
>>Male Recording: The state governors met
with their respective [cough] legislatures
convening in the capital city. The state governors
met with their respective legislatures [cough]
met with their respective [cough] legislatures
convening in the capital city. The state governors
convening in the capital city.
>>Leonard: Do you know which sound was obliterated?
>>male #5: G.
>>Leonard: G. Hum? It's hard huh? I mean it
sounds as it sounds somewhere like it's in
the word maybe legislatures. Well it is in
the word legislatures and it's the first,
oh, I guess I pushed the button a little too
fast. The answer's up there.
[laughter]
Now it's really astounding that more hands
didn't go up. [laughs]
[laughter]
It's first S in the word legislatures. So
let me play it for you again and try and hear
that.
[audio file being played]
>>Male Recording: The state governors met
with the their respective legi [cough]latures
convening in the capital city. The state governors
met with their respective legi [cough]latures
--
>>Leonard: So the reason that it's very hard
or even impossible to tell exactly where that
cough comes is that your brain fills it in.
If you didn't speak English and you heard
this you would legis l[cough]atures, legi
[cough]slatures and not the word legislatures
'cause you wouldn't know to fill it in. But
because that we speak English when you hear
this your brain fills it in just like it fills
in the visual data.
And there's a very famous experiment in the
1970's that shows how far your brain goes
and how it uses context to fill it in. They
played a similar audio file with the word
"[cough]eel" and the context at the end of
the sentence that the people were listening
to as defined, gave their brains the context
for what word was being said. And when they
played this for subjects and they didn't tell
them again what was being obliterated and
they asked them what they heard, the subjects
who heard, it was found that the cough "eel"
was on the orange reported hearing the sentence,
it was found that the peel was on the orange,
and they didn't even notice that the cough
obliterated the p in peel they just automatically
heard peel. When the last word was shoe they
heard heel and so on. So your brain uses the
context just like it did in the checkerboard
with the two squares that you thought didn't
match but did, it uses context to create the
reality for you.
So speaking of context let me show you how
hard it is to overcome that context. I'm gonna
play a song for you, part of a song for you
called Stairway to Heaven by Led Zeppelin.
So listen to it.
[Led Zeppelin singing "Stairway to Heaven"]
[guitar intro]
"If there's a bustle in your hedgerow, don't
be alarmed now,
It's just a spring clean for the May queen.
Yes, there are two paths you can go by, but
in the long run
There's still time to change the road you're
on."
[guitar fades]
Alright now, now that you've heard it forwards
I'm gonna play it backwards and I want you
to listen to it backwards and see if it makes
any sense. I don't think the words forward
made a lot of sense --
[laughter]
and I don't think --
that's just me perhaps. And I don't think
that Led Zeppelin was clever enough to design
a song that makes sense both forward and backwards,
but some people claim that it does. I don't
know, how many of you have heard about these
backwards effects? So, alright. So this is
something that for a while was quite popular
on the Web looking for messages in backwards
songs and speeches by politicians, etcetera.
So I'm gonna play this for you, what you just
heard backwards and I want you to listen carefully
and see if you can decipher the paragraph
of words that constitute the backwards song.
[Led Zeppelin singing "Stairway to Heaven"
played in reverse]
[guitar intro]
[inaudible]
[guitar fades]
Alright. Now not those of you who know this
but those of you who don't know this did you
make sense of it?
[pause]
It sound like gibberish? Yeah, it sounded
like gibberish to me when I first heard it
too and then I was shocked, shocked to find
this message in it. Let me show you. I'm gonna
play it for you now with the words of the
backwards message and listen to it and read
along and see if it makes sense to you this
time.
This is an example of, I'm gonna give you
some context for your brain to reconstruct
the reality of the backwards song.
[pause]
[Led Zeppelin singing "Stairway to Heaven"
played in reverse]
[guitar intro]
[inaudible lyrics]
[guitar fades]
So from your laughter I infer that you got
it this time.
[laughter]
So that probably sounded pretty real to you.
Now you've heard the same sounds twice: once
it sounded like gibberish and once it sounded
perfectly real. So which was reality? Is it
the second time where there was a Satanic
message or was it the first time?
Well I'm gonna play it for you another time
now and I want you to decide consciously,
I want you to override your unconscious mind,
watch the words, listen to the song, but don't
connect the words with the song this time.
I want you to hear it the first way even though
you're seeing the words.
[Led Zeppelin singing "Stairway to Heaven"
played in reverse]
[guitar into]
[inaudible lyrics]
[guitar fades]
So were you able to overcome your unconscious
mind? Could you watch the words and hear it
yet as gibberish? No, huh.
I'm gonna give you one more chance but this
time I'm guessing that you're spoiled like
I am 'cause I've heard it so many times now
I cannot, even without the words, I know the
words.
[laughter]
I'm gonna play it for you again without the
words and now I want you to hear it without
the Satanic message.
[Led Zeppelin singing "Stairway to Heaven"
played in reverse]
[guitar intro]
[inaudible lyrics]
[guitar fades]
So could you overcome it or is it still sounding
like the Satan song? Yeah.
Well so because people, because of this suggestibility
in this context that makes your brain automatically
interpret this, some people once they're told
this is there and they don't realize what's
going on they really believe that there is
a Satanic message there because what else
could it be? It does sound very real. And
I wanna thank Michael Shermer of the Skeptics
Society for the backwards song. You know the
Skeptics Society? You should check it out,
skeptics.com and one of the things he does
is go around debunking myths like this where
people find Satanic messages. You can take
any backwards sounds, come up with words that
sound similar to that, play it, and the same
effect will happen because your mind is using
that context to create the reality.
So in the rest of the talk I'm gonna talk
about social perception because the point
is that these same tricks that your mind uses
in audio and visual perception it also uses
in social perception. And these are very useful,
I don't mean to be talking about these only
because of the illusions that they create.
If you run into people that look like this
you don't want to have to always individually
analyze what is their role, what is their
job, what do they want from me, how do I interact
with them? You wanna be able to automatically
without thinking, without any effort, categorize
them and interact with them as a bus driver
or if you see policemen you have to be able
to interact with policemen without analyzing
first what are they there for, what's their
role, what's the gun mean?
[laughter]
Especially in New York. I give this talk in
New York and they all say, "Yeah, that's true."
[laughter]
Captains of industry and politicians we all
get limited data on these people and then
when we think about them especially the politicians
who we're going to have to vote for or not
vote for we form a picture of their character
and their personality, we form what's often
a much clearer picture than we have any right
to because the data that's coming into our
minds is like the data at the side of the
road, it's very fuzzy, but our minds are forming
for us a clear picture. Sometimes that clear
picture, like the picture that we get from
the side of the road, is accurate and sometimes
our clear picture is inaccurate, it's an illusion,
like the optical illusions I showed you.
And everybody that we meet in the world, your
work colleagues, your acquaintances, your
casual friends, it's something like that;
we get limited data on people and on social
situations; we get limited data when we're
going to make purchases and when we're thinking
about business decisions, but we have a clearer
picture than that data really supports and
we don't realize that the clear picture that
we have is not completely justified but it's
filled in by our unconscious minds and presented
to us as reality.
So let's talk about this a little bit in social
behavior. We're gonna talk about how your
social perception is constructed by your mind.
Since this is an election year I thought it
would be good to talk about a nice election
study.
You might be a staunch Democrat or a staunch
Republican in which case you're probably gonna
vote one way or the other no matter what.
But a good 20, 25, 30% of the population are
what we call swing voters who are in any given
election are undecided. And what they think
they're doing, what they intend to do, is
to judge the candidates based on the issues,
based on their experience, based on how competent
they are. But one of the things that they
don't realize they're doing is they're judging
people by data that's fed to them from their
unconscious mind to fill in the blanks. And
one of the things that our unconscious mind
feeds them is looks. When you look at candidates
you automatically judge competence by the
person's face.
And this shows you an example of how that
works. This was a study done in UC Irvine;
these are not the actual pictures used from
the study because the papers that were written
about it did not have the faces, so I'm illustrating
with these faces. But what they did was they
made flyers on supposedly real Congressional
races; they told the subjects of the experiment
that these are races outside of your district,
but here's a political flyer that we made
on these two candidates. And the flyer shows
their parties, their stance on some of the
issues, their experience, and a photograph
and they were asking people to pick who they
thought was the better person for the job.
But they were people outside their district
so they were not expected to recognize them.
But in reality what they did was they picked
one person to be the Democrat and one person
to be the Republican and then they had a Hollywood
makeup artist and a professional photographer
create two versions of photos of them for
the flyers. In one version was designed to
make them look less competent and another
version was designed to make them look more
competent.
Prior to this they did a little pilot study
where they studied exactly what features of
a person would make them look more or less
competent and then they used what they learned
to have these people design two versions of
each candidate.
And half the people saw the Republican candidate
in her more competent looking version and
the Democrat in her less competent looking
version, and the other half saw the Republican
in the less competent looking version and
the Democrat in the more competent looking
version. And then they compared the vote that
they would get to see what is the vote swing
just based on the degree of competence in
your picture.
And they found that when the Republican was
more competent looking, the Republican got
56%of the vote, but when she was less competent
looking she only got 44%. So there was a vote
swing there from 44 to 56, I'm sorry 58%,
there was a vote swing of 14%. So 14% of the
vote changed based purely on the person's
picture whether it was a competent looking
picture or a less competent looking picture.
So I mentioned the Skeptics Society; if you
guys are skeptical you could say, "Well, they
were told that this was a real election but
that they had nothing at stake. So this might
happen in the laboratory but does it happen
in real life?"
And fortunately a fellow at Princeton, a psychologist
named Alexander Todorov, decided to see if
this works in real life, so he did something
very impressive. He looked at about 400 elections,
gubernatorial, senatorial, congressional elections
and he gathered photos of the candidates and
paired them; this was before the 2006 elections.
And he wondered if this effect is real can
I predict the outcome of the races by these
pictures? So he had subjects come into the
lab and look at the pictures in pairs very
briefly and just pick one; which one looks
more competent? And he had hundreds of subjects
do this and he gathered statistics on which
of these candidates looked more competent.
And then he created a prediction for all those
races based not on political science, not
on party, not on the issues, based purely
on who looks more competent to the most people.
So the question is: how successful do you
think he would have been? Well, he was actually
very successful; he got 70%of the races correct
that way.
So what this indicates, this correlation is
that something is going on that when we're
judging people we're factoring in something
we don't think we're factoring which is their
appearance.
[pause]
Another thing that influences us in our social
interactions a great deal is touch. This slide
shows four different kinds of primates engaged
in grooming activities.
[laughter]
Now except for the one in the center, these
primates spend a lot of time, an hour or two
every day, doing this grooming even though
it only takes about 10 or 20 minutes to accomplish
the physical purpose of the grooming and that's
because alliances, social alliances are very
important for all primates, including us,
and by touching we create bonding and we create
trust. And so primates create their social
alliances largely through their touching and
their grooming. And the question is: what
about people?
Well touch is also very important for people
and in fact in the last few years scientists
have even discovered specialized nerves that
are mostly in your arms and your face that
don't work very well for feeling what's there,
where something is, but transmit the pleasantness
of social touch to your brain. So they seem
to be there purely for the bonding experience.
And so the question is: how much of an effect
is this? How much of your perception of a
scene or of an interaction with someone is
influenced by the touch element? We talked
about the looks element but now I'm gonna
talk about the touch element.
And my favorite experiment here was done in
France and it involves a few handsome Frenchmen
and some French, single French women. This
fellow represents the handsome Frenchman --
[laughter]
these guys were all in their 20's and they
were asked to stand on a street corner in
a town in Northern France and spend all day
for a few days propositioning single women,
single, young women who walked by. And they
were all instructed to say exactly the same
thing and this is the translation of it. They
basically say, "Hi my name's Antoine. You're
very pretty, don't have time to talk now,
can I have your phone number, I'll call you
later for a drink."
[laughter]
But to half of the women they propositioned
they were told to give a very light half second
or less touch on the shoulder or the elbow
and to the other half they weren't; they were
told not to do that. And the question was:
what kind of effect does this have on their
success rate? Well it had a great effect,
it doubled it. So 10%of the women agreed to
the date if they didn't touch them and 20%
did with the touch.
[laughter]
Again going to the skeptics side you could
say, "Well touch is actually more directly
related to sex. What about other things that
about the influence of touch in other social
situations that aren't so directly related
to the touching you might do later?"
[laughter]
And so one of the other experiments was done
in restaurants, actually two of them. In one
of the experiments they gathered a group of
waiters and waitresses instead of the men
and they told them, "When you deal with your
customers I want you somewhere during the
interaction to give them a nice light touch,"
for half of them; and for half don't. "And
we're gonna keep track of your tips and see
if touching them increases your tips."
And sure enough they found that the waitresses
and waiters averaged 14½% tips from the customers
they didn't touch and 17% from the customers
they did touch. And they did a similar experiment
on how many people take your recommendation
when you recommend the special and that went
up from 40% to 60% with the touch.
What about going to the blackboards, this
is one of my pet peeves on this study: they
said, "No one in the math class," and I've
taught math classes, "No one in the math class
will wanna go to the blackboard." So they
tested the influence of touch on kids who
wanna go to the blackboard in a difficult
statistics class and as the professor's asking
them to go the blackboard and potentially
be embarrassed, and only 9% who weren't touched
went to the blackboard but with this very
subtle touch 28% did.
Doctors, where are the doctors?
[pause]
The doctors have disappeared. Well, that's
okay.
Agreeing to take a mall survey: 53% agreed
to spend five minutes on a mall survey and
76% agreed to take it if they were given a
light touch. So this touch, and oh by the
way, in most of these studies the subjects
were debriefed afterward and one of the questions
they were asked was, "Did you notice being
touched at any time?" And most of them in
the study said that they didn't even notice
the touch.
[pause]
Finally I wanna talk about when self provides
the context. So sometimes the context in a
social situation has to do with how it matters
to you personally and your own self-image
or your own world view.
This is Salvador Dali and he famously said,
"Every morning upon awakening, I experience
a supreme pleasure: that of being Salvador
Dali, and I ask myself wonderstruck, what
prodigious thing will he do today, this Salvador
Dali?"
[laughter]
Now he may sound like a pompous ass but I
[chuckles] like this quote because this quote
is what our unconscious mind wants us all
to feel about ourselves. Because the best
chance of success we can have in life if you're
approaching some difficult problem at Google
or if you're approaching difficult graduate
school or medical school or difficult medical
problems, chemotherapy, starting a business
on your own, you have a very big advantage
if you feel that you can overcome this and
that you that don't have perhaps a totally
realistic view of what you're getting into.
And your unconscious mind is very important
helping you see that.
Let me just show you the results of that.
What happens when you ask people how good
they are at things? If you ask high school
kids, "Are you above average?" I don't know
if any of you have high school kids but you'll
probably know that they're gonna say, "Yes."
And indeed in a survey of three million high
school kids, 100% of them said they were above
average. [laughs]
[laughter]
I'm guessing they rounded up from 99.99, but.
What about the professors? Do the teachers
have a better view? So professors were asked,
"Is your work above average?" Yes, only 94%
of them thought so.
And here's some doctors, what about your doctor,
your doctor's usually confident in your diagnoses.
But in one study doctors were confident that
they had diagnosed pneumonia correctly 80%
of the time and they were only right 20%of
the time.
One of the things your mind does when it gives
you these over inflated views of yourself
is it changes the way you treat incoming data;
this is called motivated reasoning. So if
you're completely objective and you look at
data then you might judge the data by the
methodology, you might judge the data by the
weight that that particular data should hold,
in other words, is that factor that you're
testing very important? But what your unconscious
mind does is it adjusts the weight that you
give to data and it adjusts your view of the
methodology in a way to tend to confirm your
preexisting beliefs and desires.
So when you're looking at data, the human
mind does not act as a scientist who's analyzing
data objectively and drawing a conclusion
but your unconscious mind is more like a lawyer
who looks at the conclusion that you want
and adjusts the way that you look at the evidence
to tend to support that conclusion. And it's
very important this unconscious 'cause if
you try to consciously do it you're too smart
for that, you're gonna know that I'm just
fooling myself. But your unconscious can fool
you in a way that you're not aware of and
that's how these things happen.
And another thing that your unconscious does
is it adjusts your memory. Your memory, as
we'll see later, is a construction just like
your vision is and your audio and your social
perception. What you remember are the broad
strokes of things that happen just like your
eyes pick up the broad strokes of the scene
but it's fuzzy and your brain puts it together,
your memory remembers the broad strokes of
events that happen and then fills in the blanks
so that you have a very clear memory, a distinct
memory. But that memory uses things like context
in addition to data, context, prior knowledge,
beliefs, and desires.
So if you ask, for instance, students four
years out of college, "What were your grades?"
you'll find an interesting effect. They tend
to remember their A's pretty well and their
lower grades less and less.
In one study scientists gathered together
a bunch of kids who had graduated four years
earlier, got them to sign off on their transcripts,
got their transcripts so they could see what
their grades were, and the kids had no motive
to lie, and they asked them about their grades.
Well they remembered their A's 89% of the
time, 60% of their B's, 51% of their C's,
and only 29%of their D's.
So if you were in school, and I always tell
my students, "If you're getting back grades
don't worry in time your grades will improve."
[laughter]
Now in business what happens is this can cause
problems because CEO's, for instance, tend
to overpay for companies because they look
at other companies and they go, "I'm a better
CEO than that CEO. One of the problems is
that CEO didn't know how to run the company.
I can run it better." And so they end up overpaying
for the company.
So our unconscious mind creates sincere beliefs
and images of what's going on in the world,
and we believe them as being real, but they're
not necessarily based purely on data.
[pause]
This motivated reasoning was illustrated nicely
in a study in Texas. They took subjects and
the subjects were all given the data on a
case where an automobile crashed into a car,
crashed into a motorcycle and the motorcyclist
was suing the automobile driver. And they
gave them the transcript of the case, the
data, and they told half of them, "You're
gonna take the part of the motorcyclist."
And they told the other half, "You're gonna
take the part of the automobile driver. And
you're gonna pair up and negotiate your own
form of the settlement," which was between
$0 and $100,000.
So they digested all this data and they got
ready to negotiate and then the experimenter
said, "Oh wait a minute, before you do that
take your advocate's hat off, this is just
a game after all, so forget the conflict of
interest. I want you to guess what the real
settlement was and if you can guess within
$5,000 I'll give you a cash bonus. So it's
in your financial interest to be objective
here and to ignore any possible motivated
reasoning that you had when you were digesting
the data." So how did they do? Well the subjects
who were told that they were going to take
the motorcyclist part guessed on average that
a fair settlement would be $40,000, but those
who took the driver's part guessed only $20,000.
So they were unable to overcome, as I said
these are automatic, the unconscious effects
are automatic and very hard to control. So
even when money was at stake for them they
were unable to be objective in their analysis
of the case.
Let's see if this stuff happens to you. So
we'll get to those two tests that we did earlier
and the first one is called anchoring and
it shows how the context of a situation can
affect your consumer behavior. Both groups
were given this question as question number
two: "How much would you expect to pay for
this lovely hotel room in Tahiti?" Well, let
me tell you what the answers were: Group 1,
that's you guys right? You guessed on average
$1,176. So Group 2 you're probably a little
bit surprised because you guessed on the average
$304.
Well what I did do? I exercised mind control
over you guys. From over here I went like
that and I got you guys to quadruple your
offer. And how did I do that? That's because
when, I didn't give you a lot of data on the
hotel room, I gave you some pictures and it
was in Tahiti and a little information and
your brain formed some kind of image of what
this hotel room is worth. The thing is that
the difference between you guys was the first
question I asked. So Group 1 was asked, "Does
this cost more than $5500 a night?" And Group
2 was asked, "Does this cost more than $55
a night?" This is like a throw away question
'cause I think it's pretty obvious that it
is more than $55 a night and it's not more
than $5500 a night. And you probably didn't
think too much about it and thought, "Well
these questions are a little bit extreme,"
but yet it affected your conscious assessment
of what's going on.
So when you watch those late night shows and
they wanna sell you 10 steak knives for $49.95
in the end, but they start off by saying,
"These 10 steak knives are worth $700, we
normally sell them for $700 but today just
for you it's discounted to $49.95." And you're
probably thinking if you're like me, "That
$700 what BS, no one would ever pay anything
like that." But what you don't realize is
they manipulated you to thinking that the
$49.95 wasn't nearly as bad as you might think
if they hadn't given you the $700 to begin
with, as absurd as it is.
[pause]
So finally let me, let's go to the other test
which shows you how you create your own memories.
What I gave you earlier was this list over
here: candy, sour, sugar, etcetera and then
I asked you which of these words appeared
on the list.
Well I was telling you how your brain constructs
memories just like it constructs vision based
on things like context, and this is a good
illustration of that. Because the word point
was not on the list and only two of you guessed
the word point, that's pretty good and that's
normal. And the word taste was on the list
and 37 of you correctly remembered that the
word taste was on the list. But remember I
asked you to only write it down if you're
confident and if you can hear us saying the
word. So I don't think any of you should have
written down sweet because sweet wasn't on
the list. So if you remembered the word sweet
it was what we call a false memory. Your brain
reconstructed that clear as a bell, excuse
the pun, but it didn't hear anything; it's
just the gist of the list and it filled it
in for you. So I said 37 people said taste,
well 37 people also said that sweet was on
the list.
So this shows you the power of the reconstruction
of your memory and it's something to be very
cognitive of when you read about legal cases
and eyewitness testimony, but we don't have
time for that.
So let me just end with a quote from Carl
Yung that I like; I don't believe in a lot
of what he said but some of what he said was
really [inaudible]. "These subliminal aspects
of everything that happens to us may seem
to play very little part in our daily lives,
but they are the almost invisible roots of
our unconscious thoughts."
Thank you.
[laughter]
[applause]